three pro-lifers are only pro-birth they  don't care about babies after they're  born answer you have no data or evidence  to support that stupid claim besides our  position is that babies in the womb have  moral worth equal to babies outside of  course we believe babies outside have  worth that's the whole basis of our  argument our assertion is that babies in  the womb have worth and that's based on  our contention that babies and all  people outside have worth our argument  hinges on the comparison between humans  inside and outside the womb and our  contention is that there is no inherent  difference in these groups aside from  their physical location four the fetus  is just a clump of cells answer we're  all clumps of cells some of us are far  clumpier than the average infant none of  that is relevant what's relevant is  whether the fetus is a distinct and  separate human entity which he is